Dr
Zak what are the reasons behind Muslims
continually falling into these same
errors Ramadan after
Ramadan
[Music]
alhamdulillah the main reason that
Muslims keep on committing the same
errors in the month of Ramadan regarding
the rules and regulation of fasting is
lack of knowledge of the dean
of the religion of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala and the major reason for this
lack of knowledge is because most of the
Muslims they do not read the word of
Allah subhana wa tala they do not read
the Quran with
understanding neither do they read the
Hadith the authentic sayings of the last
and final messenger Prophet Muhammad
Sall Al wasallam what you Muslim should
do is read the Quran with understanding
read the sayings of the prophet and the
S of the Prophet then inshallah at least
we will have the basic knowledge of our
Dean including the rules and regulations
of fasting and Allah subhana wa ta'ala
he always opens up his pathway he gives
guidance to the Muslims but there is a
criteria whom does he guide Allah says
in the
Quran in Sur anab chapter number 29
verse number 69 that those who strive in
the way of Allah subhana wa ta'ala those
who do
J Allah subhana wa ta'ala opens his
Pathways for them so the criteria for us
to get the guidance of Allah subhana wa
taala the criteria for us where Allah
subhana wa taala will open up our
Pathways is to strive in his way to do
J and Allah says in the Quran in chapter
number
16 verse 43 as well as Surah Amia
chapter number 21 verse number 7
says which means if you do
not possess or if you
doubt then ask the person who possesses
the knowledge if you doubt anything ask
the person who
knowledgeable and alhamdulillah we have
in our
umah several Muslims who are scholars in
this de so it's our duty to ask these
Scholars these people who have the
knowledge of Islam regarding the rules
and regulations of our Dean as far
as fasting is concerned which is one of
the important pillars of Islam every
Muslim should know at least when is the
time for fasting what are the basic
rules and Regulation and today in this
age of Science and Technology it's very
easy to find it is only the negligence
of a Muslim that makes him unaware of
these things it's very easy today to
know when is the time for fasting when
does Fast begin when the time of when is
the time forar for breaking the fast
what are the things that break the fast
etc etc it is mainly due to the
negligence and ignorance of the Muslims
that we regularly keep on falling and
committing these same mistakes
furthermore what are the common errors
that are made by Muslims during the holy
month of Ramadan the common errors
committed by the Muslims in the month of
Ramadan can be broadly classified into
four categories the first category is
the common errors committed by Muslims
regarding the obligatory rules and
regulations of fasting the second
category is the common errors committed
by Muslims which are contradictory to
the Sunnah of
fasting the third category
is the errors committed by Muslims
mainly due to neglecting the obligatory
duties in Islam
and indulging in Acts which are
prohibited and the fourth category is
the other common errors committed by
Muslims in the month of
Ramadan clearly Dr Zaki it's going to be
difficult for us to um discuss all of
the common errors made by Muslims
during the month of
Ramadan in this one interview but over
the next 32 days we will insh try to
cover those issues but could you just um
state or list the most grievous mistakes
made by Muslims in the month of
Ramadan as far as the common errors that
fall in the first two categories
inshallah we'll be discussing in detail
in the next insh 30 is I will inshallah
speak about the common errors committed
in the third and fourth category before
we discuss categories three and four can
we at least list the most common errors
from sections one and
two the most Grievous amongst the errors
in the first category that is errors
committed regarding the obligatory rules
and regulations of fasting is the most
common is is that Muslims many of times
they don't do the Nia for fasting
intention is very important without Nia
without intention the fasting is not
accepted so making intention is
obligatory and we'll be discussing this
inshallah in detail insh tomorrow the
second error is that many times Muslims
even after the fud aan has started yet
they continue eating and they think that
the end ofur time is only at the end of
the FJ aan in fact the moment the fjer
aan starts the moment the beginning of
dawn starts theur time ends so this is
error which normally nullifies or
invalidates the
first the third error in the first
category is that many people they delay
paying their
and many times they pay after
the Salah if we pay the Zak
after then it is like normal charity it
does not come under the Zak so these
three are the most Grievous in the first
category the common errors committed in
the second category that is errors that
are contradicting the Sunnah of the
fasting
is number
one many people they skip
the some people they have an early suur
that is they have theur one or two hours
before the FJ time in factur is a
blessing every Muslim should have it and
the prophet said we should delay The Sur
as much as possible we should have it
till just before the F
time the third mistake committed by
Muslims in this category is that they
delay opening their fast they delay
thear and our Prophet M wasallam said
that the people will be good as long as
they hasten in Breaking thear that means
immediately after Sunset they should
break
thear the fourth common error in this
category is that many Muslims they read
unauthentic Dua
during
ifar the most authentic Dua as far Asar
is concerned
is inshallah which means
that my thirst is quenched the veins are
moistened and the a is
near inshallah God willing the reward is
near God willing
and some people when they read this Dua
for breaking the fast they say it before
breaking the
fast before they put their date in the
mouth they say this and it's contrary to
the meaning the meaning says that my
thirst has been
quenched my thirst has been quenched and
the veins have been moistened your
thirst cannot be quenched before
breaking the fire so normally it should
be said after you eat the k after you
have water and you're satisfied maybe
after some minutes after you break the
fast then you can read this
Dua inah which
means my thirst has been quenched the
wains have been
moistened the reward is near inshallah
God
willing the
sixth common error made by Muslims in
this category is that many Muslims they
eat excessively during and many of them
even eat throughout the
night the seventh common error is that
many of them they are negligent as far
ASI is concerned
because is not a they think it is no
problem if a Muslim misses T though is
not a it's a very important Sunnah and a
Muslim who misses Tavi is missing a
great deal of
reward and many Muslims who perform Tavi
they read Tavi very fast mil per hour
they try and finish it in a short time
and they defeat the purpose in fact you
should read with a moderate pace so that
people understand and they grasp the
message of Allah subhana wa tala the
ninth common error is that those who go
for in the musk many of them they
socialized during
as though it's a time to meet people and
friends which is totally contrary to the
Sunnah the 10th common error is that
many of the Muslims think that the is on
the 27th night of
Ramadan and they only worship Allah
subhana wa tala on this night in fact
the Beloved Prophet malli wasallam
said search for the in the odd nights of
the last 10 days the last Ash the 10
days therefore can fall either on the
21st night or 23rd or 25th or 27th or
29th so this is one the common errors
made by Muslims the 11th common error is
that they spend their time during
Ramadan in unproductive work rather than
spending in zikar and worshiping Allah
subhana tala they should spend the time
rather for offering besides the
compulsory Salah the the volunt Salah
the sunah Salah the 12th error made by
the Muslims is that they should do
Dua the 13th is they should ask for
forgiveness this month of
forgiveness 14th is they should read the
Quran as much as
possible to get the blessing of Allah
subhana wa tala the 15th is that they
fast and they keep themselves hungry but
basically they're not mentally prepared
for that
fast and it is as though they're staying
hungry but the main purpose of fasting
to acire TA is not
obtained this was in brief regarding the
second category can you mention briefly
again categorize the uh common errors
made in the third category
the common errors committed by Muslims
in the third category that is errors
regarding negligence in performing the
far the obligate duties in Islam is that
Muslims many of them they stay awake the
full
night they have a
early
and these
people they do not offer the F Salah
missing f Salah is a
sin many of them because they stay awake
the full night they sleep the full day
and they even miss the Z and the Salah
which is a grave sin you're trying to
acquire blessings and you are neglecting
the obligated duties which is totally
prohibited many of the
Muslims they do not give zakat those are
supposed to give zakat and zakat is one
of the pillars of Islam in which every
Muslim who has a saving of the nisab
level that is those who have a saving of
85 grams of gold they should give
2.5% of their savings every lunar year
in society it's called a
zakat and the fourth error in the third
category is that most of the Muslims
give zakat but they do not calculate the
zakat
properly as far as common errors
committed by Muslim month of Ramadan
that is indulg in prohibited acts the
most common is though these acts are
prohibited for a Muslim irrespective
whether it's a month of Ramadan or non-
Ramadan but specifically we should be
more careful we should be careful trying
to avoid these acts throughout a life
but in Ramadan we should be more careful
and the most common number one where
Muslims involve themselves is backbiting
and
slandering backbiting is a grave sin and
Allah says in the Quran in Surat 49
verse number 12 that those who backbite
they are people who eat the dead meat of
their own
brother so backbiting and sanding is one
of the gravest sins the second common
error in this category
is Muslims many of them they use false
speech they tell lies during the month
of
Ramadan the Third
is they use abusive
language which is contrary to the spirit
of Islam and of Raman the fourth is they
use VGA
language and the fifth is they involve
themselves in
gossiping the sixth
is some of them involve in false
action the seventh is many of the
Muslims to kill time they listen to
music and un Islamic
songs which is totally prohibited in
Islam the eighth common error is many of
the Muslims to kill time they watch un
Islamic television programs and un
Islamic
movies the ninth common error committed
by Muslim is that many of the Muslims
they read un Islamic magazines un
Islamic books Islamic
pictures which all prohibited in Islam
the 10th common
error done by Muslims in this month is
many of them they go to un Islamic sites
on the internet which is again
prohibited the 11th common error is that
they spend
excessively and they commit
extravagance and the 12th is
there is a lot of wastage of food so
this was in brief
regarding the list of mistakes done by
Muslims commonly in the third category
that is indulging in Acts which are
prohibited and neglecting acts which are
F in
Islam so Dr zakya what are the other
common errors committed by Muslims
during the month of
Ramadan the other common errors ComEd by
Muslims in the month of Ramadan that is
the fourth category is number one is
that many of the Muslims they stay awake
the full night and then they sleep in
the day and they do the normal activity
at the night time and sleep in the
daytime they're converting day into
night and night into day and the whole
purpose of fasting is defeated the
second error in this category is that
many of the Muslims they remain lazy and
they're inactive during the daytime
which is contrary to the spirit of
fasting
the third common error is that many of
the Muslims they try and kill their time
during the day by
playing by amusement by games which
defeats the purpose
again the fourth common error is Muslims
they give lavish ifar parties and they
spend a lot of money mly trying to show
off the fifth common error many of the
Muslims they ask the wom folk in their
family to prepare a variety of dishes
forar and for thus making the women in
the family spend the majority of the
time in the kitchen in fact the family
should spend most of the time in
Remembering Allah subhana tala and if
the women folk do more duas inshallah
even the men will benefit
even their sin will be forgiven
inshallah the sixth common error is that
many of the Muslims they
renovate the house and the shop in the
month of Ramadan spend more time in that
than remembering Allah subhana tala the
seventh common error is that many of the
Muslims they spend their nights instead
of remembering Allah subhana wa taala in
activities which are unproductive
for
example they spend their
time in excessive socializing after that
is eight error ninth is many of the
Muslims they spend many nights and most
parts of their nights in
shopping the 10th common error is many
of the Muslims they spend most of the
time in the night in
eating the 11th is many of the Muslims
they spend their time in
robing and in loitering during the night
and the 12th common error is the last 10
days of Ramadan are mainly the days in
which the Muslims should do more I but
most of the Muslims they spend time in
shopping in
celebrating and preparing themselves for
Eid and most of them spend time in
activities that are unproductive rather
than spending the time in I these are
some of the other Comm errors which
Muslims commit and I hope inshallah that
they will abstain from these errors